make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing our series on two
powerful for Marvel movies we're gonna
be a little obscure here and we're gonna
cover the character of zom now ssam
here's the thing about zom alright zom
is is crazy powerful okay so so why in
the clock back right to strange tales
issues 155 through 157 right this is
kind of the irony of it all the let me
tribunal actually debuted in 157 as a
result of this story but this was a
story that took place involving umar
invading Earth and then getting into a
fight with dr. strange now who is umar
okay so a Marvel Comics you guys have
heard of Dormammu apprec guys have uh
there's also his sister Umar they're a
member of a race called the fall team FA
LT I and II the file teen itself now the
fall teen are basically beings of like
pure magical energy and they exist
inside their own dimension the issue
with this was that with Umar and
Dormammu they weren't like the rest of
the fall team me I mean they were in
terms of power but they wanted more like
physical power
right like armies different things like
that and the result was that when one of
their members called Cinna fer tried to
stop them they basically killed him and
the result was that they were banished
from their own realm and they took up
residence in the Dark Dimension where
they've resided ever since so if those
you guys remember Dormammu from the
Doctor Strange film that's how he got to
the Dark Dimension that's kind of his
origin story summed up in an exceedingly
fast way but suffice it to say these
folks are crazy powerful but I mean
they're they're exceedingly powerful now
the way the story played out was that at
the time umar had invaded earth and then
dr. strange wasn't able to defeat her i
mean you're basically talking about
somebody who's equal empowered to
Dormammu and dr. strange couldn't defeat
her and the result was that dr. strange
was looking for like a last desperate
attempt to win and one of the things
he'd been told by the ancient one who
was that at one point in time a being
named dom was basically locked away by
the combined forces of eternity and the
ancient one or at least one of the one
of the sorceress Supremes as well as
door mama right like it took all of them
to basically defeat this guy because he
was just so powerful nobody really knows
where he came from nobody really knows
who created him he was just there one
day he's almost like man GOG in the
sense that presumably some race some
were created and managed out of anger or
something like that but we don't really
have an answer to it regardless the
result was that dr. strange saw this as
an opportunity to summon zom and then
use Dom as a means to defeat you mark
the issue with this is that when zom
showed up and did defeat
he then turned to dr. strange it was
like I'm going to eradicate your
universe and every other universe in the
multiverse right I'm going to destroy
everything and where dr. strange tried
to control him the issue is that zom was
so astronomically powerful that he
simply couldn't be stopped right there
was nothing dr. strange could have done
and that was that was a thing like dr.
strange and like all the reality
manipulating characters and like all the
Avengers and all the x-men all the
superheroes and all the villains they
all could have van together and they all
would have been destroyed they all would
have been wiped out by a zombie cuz he's
just that insanely capable in terms of
the power he possesses this one into
strange tales 1:57 and the battle raged
on right like it was just this huge
thing and it was like Doctor Strange is
gonna lose and everything is gonna be
destroyed and then suddenly Zhaan gets
whisked away it's just kind of like I've
had enough of you you're done your
purpose is served you were someone here
to defeat Umar Umar z' now defeated gone
and and and just like with a wave of his
hand
za was gone and that was a living
tribunal and that's what the Living
Tribunal made its debut because what it
said to Doctor Strange was you basically
summoned a being of incredible power it
would have wiped out the entirety of the
multiverse you have no clue what you've
done you don't really even understand
the power you possess because of that
you don't really deserve to to have this
kind of power and I'm gonna destroy the
earth now it's kind of a thin jump from
A to B from you know you made a mistake
to I'm going to wipe out your world or
why not universe because of it ah it's
kind of a big jump tonight but hey
Comics back in the day I guess it made
sense but the overall idea here is that
it took the Living Tribunal the judge of
the multiverse to successfully defeat
xuong and that's the kind of power we're
talking about if right now let's say
that that Donnie Cage was writing you
know with him writing Doctor Strange
let's say right now with everything
that's going on Galactus consuming
Dormammu and then like dr. strange
summoning zom as a means to defeat
Galactus za would do it he would destroy
him and then he would wipe out
everything else it's his character is
just destruction right like all it wants
to do is wipe out and destroy everything
it can get his hands on and that's one
of the reasons why the character is just
too powerful for the MCU one because of
the power he possesses and two because
of this desire to destroy everything it
gets kind of intriguing because one of
the things that I guarantee people are
going to ask is like who would win
between zom and like the marquee of
death or something like that I don't
know like I have no clue there's no way
to know I mean when you're talking about
that level of power there really it
really doesn't matter you're talking
about a level of power so extreme that
with a wave of his hand a beam kid wipe
out an entire universe it might as well
just be a stalemate that's why he's just
too powerful is because with someone's
list
for example the marquee of death let's
talk about the marquee of death for a
second right let's talk about Clyde
Winship alright Clyde windchime with the
power he has right waving his hand and
wiping out an entire universe the more
key of death is really more like really
kind of held a vendetta against like
Reed Richards right so it was he was a
being that just like had motivation and
had Drive and was just like I want to
kill superheroes and I want to target
them specifically the Fantastic Four and
then just kind of call it a day and
that's it like the power he possessed
was more for like messing with people or
achieving his own individual goals uh
you look at somebody like Dormammu is
acquiring power right like like
expanding his sphere of influence
outside the Dark Dimension
with zom it's not that way it's just a
desire to destroy that's why he's very
similar to man GOG right like man GOG is
some being that was created out there
somewhere in the in the universe uh that
basically each handles all the hatred
and and anger of his dead race and then
like will wipe out the Asgardians like
like everybody in Asgard is afraid of
man God including Odin himself I guess
that's kind of the that's kind of the
nature of the beast right like man God
first shows up and like Odin craps his
pants that's basically what happened in
the story oh it's just like okay so like
we're screwed ah we're dunzo like yeah
that's that's really what it was with
zom it's the same way and how do you
combat that right like how do you take a
character like that whose sole purpose
is to annihilate and destroy everything
because that's what it does and then
throw it into the MCU and makes it make
it work because if Marvel did this in
like listen they did this like 20 years
well this is like like like 20 39 and
they're at least the time that we're
making this video is 20 39 and you have
like Franklin Richards right like this
reality-warping character whose powers
on par with like Galactus and you've got
Galactus himself and maybe you have like
hyper storm the son of Franklin Richards
from the future and maybe you have like
mr. M and you have I don't know who else
where you have other maybe some cosmic
entities or something like that it
wouldn't matter
zom would still destroy them all it
would take the Living Tribunal to step
in and you can't really you can't really
deal with that kind of power the MCU is
really not set up for that kind of power
it's not set up to to introduce a
character like that and then make that
character work because none of the
heroes would survive the only way to do
that is to scale him down right because
even Doctor Strange of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is weak now he's
really more on par with like his comic
book version but the reason why I say
he's weak is because in the comics he's
weak he was much much stronger back in
the day at the time that story was
written strange tales 156 and 157 Doctor
Strange was painfully pyro was insane
how powerful he
there's a spell for him to do anything
and so if a being showed up who could
overpower dr. strange it meant something
he were just like okay so like they are
a broken character like they're they're
super super ope that was the basis
behind how he functioned like let me
tell you somethin those shows up with
like the Infinity Gauntlet in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and like zom is there
as almost be like who cares
and just like wave his hand destroy the
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos has done and
the day is saved and then he blows it
obliterates the world so the day is not
saved now like that's basically what
would happen like that that's how this
character unfolds it's it's the best way
I know how to describe it it's the best
way I know how to explain someone like
that because with that level of power
the ability to manipulate and destroy
entire universes it's astronomical right
it's a huge amount of power that's out
there and because of that you can't
really make that work you can't really
take that concept put into the MCU and
then expect it to be successful because
again the Marvel Cinematic Universe
doesn't really set up for that I mean
there might be ways around it like if
they did invoke the Living Tribunal ah
then that would probably work but any
kind of power that originates from a
singular universe and is confined to
that singular universe so like an
Infinity Gauntlet or something like that
it's not gonna work against him it's a
level of power that is relative to
everything in its universe against a
multiversal force it doesn't work that
way it's like saying that one is bigger
than two it's weird but I don't know I
mean it would be cool to see I mean if
they scaled him down and power to a huge
degree and made him someone who is like
slightly more powerful than dr. strange
Ben sure then like all the other
characters can all team up and they can
all fight zom and then defeat him and
that they would be saved but the purpose
behind him the the the reason why zom is
so fearsome is because he's so powerful
right like he going to read World War
Hulk and it's this idea that like
against the world breaker Hulk dr.
strange channeled the power of zom he
was just like channeling a fraction of
zoms power
zom was even back in full form if he was
I would have been over like that like if
I would have been done quick fast and in
a hurry and everything would have been
obliterated it's just easy just it's
almost like he's a representation of
death right like this the destruction of
all things I mean there already is a
being out there that already is a cosmic
entity that represents the destruction
of everything but if that didn't exist
it would be zombie cuz just how
outrageously powerful he is it's the
best way I know how to explain it
imagine a being who can do virtually
anything and it is short of the Living
Tribunal in power but more powerful than
like Odin and the cosmic entities the
other sky fathers Doctor Strange
the ancient one all that kind of good
stuff this is he's just right there in
the middle he's right there in the
middle word he can't be defeated by
anybody on earth or in the multiverse
short of the Living Tribunal and that's
really the only way - the only way to
beat him someone like protege could do
it cuz he just copies powers but aside
from that like it would take somebody
like that somebody with mimicry on a
universal or multiversal level and then
that would that would basically be it so
I don't know let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section let
me he said we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explain - make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]